universal healthcare is a long contested
political point in the united states
and in 2020 it seems that its future is
as uncertain as ever
donald trump and joe biden's approaches
to health care are very different
so let's dive into these two candidates
proposals and how they could affect you
in 2010 the obama administration passed
the affordable care act you might also
know this
as the aca or obamacare and it was one
of the largest health care reforms in
modern history in the united states
the affordable care act greatly expanded
health care to citizens by
providing subsidies and requiring
universal enrollment when it was first
implemented
to put it into perspective in 2010 22.3
percent of americans were uninsured
in 2016 just two years after states
implemented the aca
and expanded medicaid that number
dropped to 12.4 percent
president donald trump has been highly
critical of the affordable care act
even before he became president a lot of
his 2016 presidential
election campaign was based off of him
promising to repeal the affordable care
act
and replace it with something better
however
four years later he still has not come
out with a replacement plan
however he has done numerous things to
try and repeal the affordable care act
or weaken it piece by piece under trump
key parts of the law have been undercut
the trump administration has cut back on
spending for in-person enrollment
assistance centers
and it ended cost sharing subsidies
these
in-person enrollment assistance centers
were super important for helping people
get
access to the resources they needed to
navigate the marketplace
and to enroll in coverage cost sharing
subsidies were also
important because they helped insurers
pay for out-of-pocket costs
for low-income americans who couldn't
afford it
together these two actions by president
trump
have resulted in lower enrollment
numbers
and raised premiums according to the
center on budget and policy priorities
a separate analysis from the kaiser
family foundation
actually found that silver plan premiums
increased from seven percent
to 38 as a result of ending cost-sharing
subsidies
president trump passed an executive
order in september that protected people
with pre-existing conditions from being
denied health care coverage
interestingly enough though this was
already something that was in the
affordable care act
so a lot of critics and analysts have
said that trump is putting himself in a
position to simply
rebrand the affordable care act as
something else to make it potentially
more appealing to more people
within the republican party also a lot
of policy analysts are saying that this
executive order is largely symbolic and
by itself
without additional legislation for a
replacement to
the aca this executive order does
absolutely nothing to protect people
joe biden was part of the obama
administration when the affordable care
act originally passed
he has come out with a plan to enhance
it
and that means lowering costs and
increasing coverage for americans
joe biden's health care plan would
create a new public health insurance
option
that would work similarly to medicare
all americans would have access to this
option whether they're
self-employed or even if they are
offered
insurance through their employers anyone
will be able to turn to this public
option
and choose coverage that best suits them
joe biden's health care plan
would also increase tax credits and
remove the 400
income cap on tax credit eligibility to
help lower insurance premiums
joe biden will also lower the limit of
how much
cost of coverage can be regarding income
currently
it can be as much as 9.86 of someone's
income
he wants to lower it to 8.5 joe biden's
health care plan would also
offer coverage to americans who are
eligible for expanded medicaid
but live in states that refused the
medicaid expansion
this would result in an estimated 4.9
million americans getting access to
health insurance
an analysis by the kaiser family
foundation finds biden's plans would
significantly lower the cost of
nearly all current enrollees and
prospective enrollees who might
currently be priced out of the market
the analysis includes an example of a 40
year old making 50
dollars per year saving 32 percent on
his gold plan premiums
each month one important thing to
consider about biden's plan however
is that it will increase federal
spending the current federal deficit
sits at 3 trillion an all-time high
and adding more costs like this could
become a major source of contention
among lawmakers in washington
overall joe biden and donald trump have
two very different
visions of health care in america and
how they want to achieve coverage for
americans
joe biden has an extensive plan to
enhance the affordable care act
and his major goals are to increase
coverage
and lower premiums donald trump has long
been saying that he wants to repeal the
affordable care act
and replace it with something new
however we have yet to see
any form of a replacement plan from his
administration
notably the affordable care act will
face a supreme court hearing just one
week after the election
so the future of the aca is as uncertain
as ever
and we'll have to follow along closely
to see what happens next
[Music]
you